[Música]
eeuu contiene el aliento mientras se
realizan los últimos conteos de votos
por correo en estados clave joe biden
conquisto wisconsin y michigan y ya suma
264 votos electorales frente a 214 de
donald trump que no obstante líder en
pensilvania y georgia donde aún no
finaliza el conteo nevada podría ser
definitivo para el fin de la contienda
tenemos análisis
tras un cambio en la balanza de los
estados clave del norte del presidente
de donald trump declaró que sospecha
fraude y pidió un recuento en el estado
de wisconsin además se presentó una
demanda para impedir que siga el conteo
en michigan y para evitar que sean
recibidos más sufragios en pensilvania
bailén reiteró que esperará hasta que
sean contados todos los apoyos
y mientras tanto en el senado los
partidos republicano y demócrata están
en un virtual empate que les otorga 48
escaños y 47 respectivamente la cámara
de representantes- se la lleva hasta el
momento del partido demócrata
[Música]
buenas noches aquí comienzan las
noticias de france 24 mi nombre es
ángela gómez e iniciamos este
informativo con la que es la noticia en
desarrollo que tiene al mundo en
expectativa en eeuu un día después de la
jornada de elecciones generales continúa
el conteo de los votos en algunos
estados clave para determinar quién será
el nuevo presidente y la demora no es
gratuita esta fue una fiesta electoral
histórica no sólo por el récord de votos
a distancia sino por ser la elección de
mayor participación desde 1908 aún se
mantienen en suspenso los resultados por
el momento jobvite n tiene 264 votos
electorales y donald trump 214 no se
sabe de alaska nevada michigan a georgia
carolina del norte ni pensilvania como
decíamos joe biden lidera con los votos
electorales y así las cosas sólo está a
seis apoyos de cantar la victoria
mientras tanto el presidente y aspirante
a la reelección de donald trump desde el
partido republicano tiene 214 votos del
colegio electoral pero no todo está
dicho porque aún es siguen en suspenso
cinco estados
incluyendo a nevada a georgia y
pensilvania con sus valiosos 20 votos
electorales en estos tres estados se
podría definir el futuro del país
desde wilmington en el estado de
delaware el candidato demócrata joe
biden reiteró hoy su llamado a la
prudencia y su confianza en el sistema
electoral mientras que avanza el conteo
de votos pero se mostró confiado en que
la tendencia podría darle los 270 votos
electorales que necesita para llegar a
la casa blanca biden llamó a la unión
del país estas fueron sus palabras
tras una larga noche es claro que
estamos ganando en suficientes estados
270 votos electorales para ganar a la
presidencia yo estoy aquí para declarar
que ganamos estoy aquí para reportar
cuando la cuenta esté finalizada que
creemos que seremos los ganadores oscar
con todos los votos contados hemos
ganado
wisconsin por 200 por 20 mil votos
virtualmente el mismo margen que el
presidente trompo obtuvo en ese estado
hace cuatro años y hace pocos minutos se
pronunció en la red social 'twitter'
donald trump y dijo nuestros abogados
pidieron acceso total pero que de bueno
hace eso el daño ya está hecho a la
integridad de nuestro sistema y a la
elección presidencial esto es lo que
debería discutirse
para conocer más detalles vamos a
conversar con diana castañeda nuestra
corresponsal en washington
buenas noches para usted diana y nos
están los intercambios entre los 12
candidatos indirectamente
así es básicamente la campaña del
presidente de donald trump ha preparado
una ofensiva de demandas frente a la
manera en cómo han avanzado estos
últimos resultados el día de hoy con
demandas para que se detenga el conteo
de votos electorales en los estados de
pensilvania y de michigan también una
demanda para que se haga un reconteo en
el estado de wisconsin y esto ha sido
criticado por el gobernador de
pensilvania tom wolfe quien ha dicho que
esto básicamente va en contra del
derecho de los ciudadanos
estadounidenses a elegir de manera libre
a sus gobernantes también bailén ha
dicho que va a luchar para que cada voto
en los eeuu sea contado y
definitivamente pues a tan solo cerca de
6 votos electorales de qué vaivén se
pudiera convertir en el presidente de
los eeuu todavía quedan varios estados
para determinar el futuro de quién será
el nuevo residente de la casa blanca
pero desde ya el presidente de donald
trump a través de sus redes sociales
y ha dicho a sus seguidores que den la
batalla para que no se roben estas
elecciones gracias a ustedes diana y lo
que seguimos es atentos a los
desarrollos de esta noche
y es que como usted decía en la
incertidumbre de cerradas batallas en
los estados clave que aún faltan por
declarar su color donald trump y joe
biden se alistan para una eventual
batalla legal la campaña del presidente
pidió un recuento de votos en wisconsin
en donde bardem fue declarado ganador y
por otra parte presentó una demanda para
impedir que siguiera el conteo en
michigan de que ya se declaró azul
espera también una respuesta de la corte
suprema para qué pensilvania no reciba
más votos
inicio en las urnas pero la batalla por
la casa blanca entre joe biden y donald
trump podría terminar en los tribunales
el conteo de los votos sigue aumentando
la ventaja del candidato demócrata
hayden ganó en wisconsin por un estrecho
margen pero la campaña del mandatario
pidió un recuento de los votos
argumentando irregularidades en varios
condados
el equipo de camps también anunció una
demanda para evitar que continuará el
conteo de papeletas en michigan donde va
a ir en lidera dice que no tuvieron
acceso como observadores y exigen
revisar los votos
eso se acabó nos vamos a apegar nos
vamos a ganar la elección y de hecho ya
le hemos ganado es cuestión de votar
contar los votos con justicia la batalla
también se centra en pensilvania que
tiene hasta el viernes para contar las
boletas enviadas con fecha del 3 de
noviembre así lo determinó el tribunal
superior del estado pero los
republicanos apelaron la decisión en la
corte suprema que tiene la última
palabra
donald trump aseguró que el máximo
tribunal resolvería el resultado de la
contienda el presidente instaló allí
tres jueces y reforzó una mayoría de
seis magistrados conservadores frente a
tres liberales los demócratas temen que
los jueces puedan apoyar los planes del
líder republicano vamos al análisis con
nuestro especialista rafael piñero es
profesor de relaciones internacionales
de la universidad externado de colombia
rafael e buenas noches buenas noches
como está mucho gusto saludarla
continuamos entonces con este
cubrimiento ya anoche conversamos
bastante largo y ahora le tengo que
preguntar qué tan factible es que donald
trump tenga éxito en sus demandas bueno
sin duda alguna las querellas jurídicas
será un elemento que se esperaba no sólo
en pensilvania sino
eventualmente en wisconsin y michigan
donde pidió detener el conteo de los
votos puede que haya diferencias
diferentes visiones e interpretaciones
jurídicas que se harían más difícil
conocer el resultado yo creo que es
pertinente tener en cuenta que el
colegio electoral se tiene que reunir el
próximo 14 de diciembre vamos a mirar
cómo se desarrollan esos conteos la
corte del estado de pensilvania que
había está el viernes y la solicitud de
apelar esa decisión ya fue elevada a la
corte suprema de justicia no
necesariamente haya una victoria fácil
de el presidente donald trump a pesar de
haber elegido a tres jueces de esa corte
sino que es la interpretación en derecho
de lo que entiendan los honorables
magistrados lo que determinará la
apelación final
bien y entretanto eso es la pelea legal
por un lado pero el mapa electoral nos
dice que nevada podría ser el estado que
le pone fin a esta elección entregas
seis votos electorales y son los que le
faltan a joe biden para llegar a los tan
preciados 270 con los que se proclama un
presidente en eeuu inicialmente el
estado de nevada habría dicho que
tendría resultados concluyentes el día
jueves no obstante lo anterior
a finales de la noche en la costa oeste
se espera que haya un nuevo
pronunciamiento y miraremos si es
definitivo si es decisivo el resultado
para saber si esos seis votos
electorales se van a el candidato
jobvite hay que tener en cuenta los dos
centros urbanos más grandes e
influyentes las vegas nevada y la ciudad
de reno en ese sentido en los centros
urbanos usualmente los demócratas
obtienen unos muy buenos resultados
electorales y habría que mirar en los
suburbios que se encuentran alrededor de
esas grandes ciudades
reflejan lo que las grandes ciudades han
venido mostrando pero también hay un
elemento a tener en cuenta tanto el
candidato de joe biden como el
presidente
donald trump han demostrado en otros
estados sobrepasar con amplias
expectativas lo que tenían inicialmente
planeado en términos de votos es decir
el comportamiento de ambos ha sido
significativamente positivo y tanto en
el estado de nevada como en el estado de
arizona hay todavía un gran número de
votos por contar nada está comprado en
este momento no se llevan ni siquiera
dos puntos de diferencia en nevada y por
eso mi siguiente pregunta si en nevada
no se define esta elección entonces los
ojos se van para pensilvania se cumplió
rafael la predicción de los espejismos
rojos en la madrugada los números
empezaron a cambiar el color de los
estados que inicialmente se creían una
victoria republicana y de aquí las
declaraciones de donald trump a que sin
prueba se dice que hay fraude los
problemas del sistema electoral
estadounidense comenzaron prácticamente
con la pandemia los gobernadores y las
autoridades locales le pidieron
insistentemente al presidente de la
república
que aumentará el presupuesto destinado
para poder contratar a más personas y
agilizar ese conteo de votos que se
preveía iba a ser abrumadoramente
importante desde el mes de abril o mayo
cuando se evidenció que eventualmente no
podrían realizarse normalmente las
elecciones en noviembre es decir este
debate ya lo llevamos durante varios
meses
teniendo ahora bien en pensilvania hay
una particularidad muy importante como
usted lo mencionó los republicanos
fueron juiciosamente a votar a las urnas
pero los demócratas se acercaron
eventualmente y masivamente a votar por
correo o por correo ese hecho hace que
poco a poco joe biden haya venido
reduciendo de manera significativa la
ventaja inicial que el precio con la
ventaja inicial que nos acostamos en la
noche de ayer entonces qué pasa hay que
tener en cuenta que las ciudades más
importantes
filadelfia y pittsburgh no han
finalizado completamente
con dado particular en el nor este que
va a ser decisivo que es el condado de
erie se considera que ese condado
históricamente es el oráculo del estado
de pensilvania las diferencias entre el
presidente donald trump y el candidato
joe ban se han venido acercando de
manera importante en ese condado que
reflejan en términos generales lo que ha
sido el conteo total en el estado de
pensilvania 20 votos electorales que
definirían al ganador de la contienda
rafael pues hablamos de más adelante o
seguramente mañana para ver el que nos
dicen los resultados y bueno además de
la elección presidencial también están
en disputa 470 sillas en el congreso
estadounidense de ellas 35 corresponden
a la renovación en el senado y 435 serán
en la cámara de representantes en la
cámara baja hasta el momento 203 sillas
son para el partido demócrata que
retendría la mayoría que ya ostentaba en
la legislatura pasada y 188 sillas son
para los republicanos en cuanto al
senado el período pasado estuvo dominado
por republicanos y en este momento
registra a 47 para los demócratas y 48
para los publica
aún hay en juego cinco sillas para ser
asignadas y esta elección en el congreso
deja datos interesantes en delaware con
el 86% de los votos en el primer
distrito del estado sara mcbride se
convirtió en la primera senadora trans
el demócrata mark kelly ganó en el
estado de arizona y será quien pase a
ocupar el escaño del senado que durante
décadas fue del fallecido veterano de
guerra john mccain missouri un estado
con un 83% de población blanca tendrá
por primera vez a una congresista
afroamericana se trata de tribus
la contienda también se ha movido en las
redes sociales twitter censuró trinos
del mandatario donald trump por ser
engañosos incluyendo uno en el que
sugirió el fraude electoral
luís muñoz o nos reporta desde la
redacción de france 24
el 26 de mayo tweeter sorprendió al
mundo cuando avisó que la cuenta de
donald trump publicaba información
dudosa una situación que se ha vuelto a
repetir en campaña electoral y que no se
ha detenido una vez se están contando
los votos en los últimos días la red
social ha estado tapando algunos de los
tuits del todavía presidente trump en
los que denuncia un supuesto fraude de
los demócratas para hacerle perder la
elección algo que aunque twitter ha
tratado de evitar parece haberse
finalizado entre influencers cercanos al
partido republicano y la extrema derecha
por su parte facebook en lugar de
esconder los mensajes que difunden
noticias falsas publica información para
contextualizar y contradecir el bulo
estas estrategias han sido consideradas
de censura por parte de eric trump el
hijo del presidente sin embargo las
miradas internacionales de
organizaciones de derechos humanos como
human rightswatch no ponen sus ojos en
los demócratas sino que lo hacen en los
republicanos y aseguran que la
declaración de trump sobre su victoria
fue prematura e irresponsable cuando aún
no se habían contado todos los votos en
el mundo político reina el silencio
internacional sin embargo existe la
preocupación de la unión europea sobre
las tensiones en el conteo de votos
el primer ministro de eslovenia yaneth
cansa felicito a trump y comparó a
bailén con el dictador yugoslavo
milósevic ya volvemos
[Música]